so welcome to today's webinar i'm peter
cooper
this is going to be a webinar to talk
about changes that are coming to the way
you log into your ncbi account
sherry bailey from our help desk who's a
specialist in the ncbi accounts
is going to be speaking to you today
today we're going to handle questions a
little differently than we normally do
on our webinars
because this is such a large audience
what we did was we allowed you to submit
questions ahead of time when you
registered
and so we'll answer those at the end but
you can answer you can ask questions and
we have two people from
are actually three people who are
experts in the minds bi
world who can answer your questions
david brodsky
kimberly purdle and margaret rose can
answer those
in the question spot and we'll compile
all those and we'll add them to the faq
that we have available on our blog the
url there for the faq
is on this slide and i think uh sherry's
going to talk a little bit more about
that
take it away sherry thank you and thank
you for joining us
today we will be covering major
questions about the changes that will
affect the way you directly log into
your ncbi account
answer a few questions from our mailbag
and provide information on where to find
the most
up-to-date information
let's start with why the answer is
simple
we take the security and privacy of your
account
seriously by transitioning to third
parties
who have modern and industry standard
security practices
it allows us to focus on improving your
ncbi experience
after logging in
here is a basic timeline for the ncbi
direct login retirement
starting on tuesday march 16th
users will no longer be able to create a
direct
login account in june of this year
there will be a login wizard to help
convert
direct login accounts to the third party
option
next june 2022 you will no longer be
able
to log in directly to ncbi and must use
your third-party sign-in option
to access your account
who does this affect users
who create an ncbi username and password
to sign in directly to ncbi
what are your options if you log in
directly to ncbi
you can create a new third-party account
or link to an existing account that you
may currently have
like google microsoft ura commons nih
facebook
and in most cases your affiliated
institution or organization
once your third party account is linked
to your current ncbi account
you are all set we will take a look at
login.gov
as a third party option and how to link
it
momentarily before we go any further
i want to assure you that nothing within
your account changes
meaning the information inside your
account such as my bibliography saved
searches
bio sketches say preferences like
filters
and of course your api keys and
submissions are not
affected the only thing that changes is
how you get to the information
if you log in directly to ncbi
you have heard me mention direct ncbi
login here's what it looks like
over on the left if you click the ncbi
login
to sign in with your ncbi username and
password
and over on the right by going directly
to the ncbi
account page and signing in directly
into ncbi
here are some third-party options that
you may use
to link your ncbi account quite a few of
these should look familiar
google microsoft facebook era commons if
you're a nih grant holder
and nih more logins like orcid which
provides
a unique researcher identifier and if
your organization
is a member of in commons which includes
a lot of colleges universities and
organizations
and last but not least login.gov
login.gov is an option that protects
user information with the highest
standards of digital security
let me quickly show you how easy it is
to set up an account
first enter the email address that you
would like to associate with the account
second check your email for the
confirmation link
click the confirmation link and then
fourth create a strong password
one of the main reasons i personally
like login.gov
is that it offers a second layer of
security
meaning that you can select one or more
than one
of the methods below you can
receive a security code by text message
or phone call
by using an app on a cell phone computer
or tablet to get the code
use a security key if you already have
one if you're unfamiliar it's a physical
device that often looks like a flash
drive
and sometimes you can plug it directly
into your computer
use your government or military piv card
and last but not least 10 backup codes
are provided that you can print out and
keep in a safe place
once you know the account that you would
like to link
you are ready to begin the final stages
although my example is for login.gov use
the exact same steps to link any of the
partners
third party account
step one log in directly to your ncbi
account
these screens should look familiar step
2
locate your username on the upper right
corner
and click the link which will take you
to your account
settings step 3 locate
the linked accounts box and click change
located on the right but before we move
on
as you can see in my example i have
linked more than one third party option
i like to think of my account as a room
with many doors to enter
linking your account to multiple
third-party options
is great for students staff and faculty
who may have who may be switching
institutions and lose logging
credentials
from the former institution let's move
to step four
type in the third party account that you
will be linking
click the link which will take you to
the website in this case login.gov
and provide credential
congratulations you have linked your
account
you should see a confirmation message
and the account name
appearing in your linked account
to the right you can unlink your account
at any time
by clicking on the red x
this change is easy and necessary
so we can focus on making your ncbi
resource experience
better keeping in mind it only affects
those
who sign in directly and you have
multiple
third-party options to link your ncbi
account to
let's take a quick look again at the
timeline
the ways that you can stay up to date
with this and other changes at ncbi
as well as answer some of your questions
from our mailbag
march 16th is the end of creating a
direct ncbi login account
in june 2021 there will be a login
wizard for those who have not
updated their direct login information
and in june 2022 the ncbi
direct login retires we are constantly
updating
the frequently asked questions section
and is
also a great place to start the faqs can
be found
at ncbi insights stay tuned because some
of your questions
from today will be appearing here as
well
you may have noticed on the right you
can also sign up for our listserv
and rsse you can also follow us on
twitter
facebook youtube linkedin github
or the ncbi insights blog
and as always feel free to write us at
info
at
dot ncbi.nlm.nih.gov i would like to
thank everyone who wrote in
and peter could you please assist me by
reading uh
four or five questions from our mailbag
yeah
thanks sherry so these are some
questions that we gleaned from the
questions that you submitted when you
registered and there are lots and lots
of questions in the questions pod
and they're being answered many of them
probably still as we speak and as we
said before we're going to add those to
the faq that's on
that's on the blog so if you feel like
your question's not getting answered
orally today you'll certainly get it up
there on the faq
so here's several of those questions
that you all submitted
um the first question is i log into
docline via the google
method can i use the same google
username and password to log into ncbi
is there one type of login that's better
than another for nih
or docline dotline and your ncbi
accounts are totally separate
if you prefer to link your account to
google or
any of the partner third-party party
methods
please do so the login is a type of
personal preference
and it's also dependent on what your
organization allows
okay thanks sherry another question is
our it
locks us out of social media like gmail
and our institution is not part of the
in commons
will we still be able to establish an
account and sign in the new way
absolutely you have the option of
login.gov for example
if your organization does not appear on
the in commons list
you can always ask your organization
system administrator to contact
your respective federation consortium to
become a member
additional information about this can
also be found on our login page
okay thanks sherry uh another question
will login.gov accounts work properly
when going through a library's proxy
yes proxies should work properly
if you find that you're having a login
issue with any of the
party option first attempt to log in
outside of the proxy
to make sure that the arrow is not
within the account
after you confirm the issue is the proxy
please contact your it department for
assistance
if they're unable to assist you have
that person contact the ncbi help desk
and we will work with them directly to
troubleshoot the issue
okay thanks uh next question is
um how can i keep my account content
since i have a direct login
your account information like my
bibliography say searches collections
api keys remain intact
linking your choice of third-party login
option
to your current ncbi account will
provide the access to your current
account
okay thanks sherry so that's all the
questions that we're going to answer
today
live but please um take a look at the
faq
uh after the webinar you know give us a
few days to get these things updated but
we'll have
the other questions answered up there
also you know please
contact us at info if you have any
trouble you know
linking your accounts or anything like
that you can write to the help desk at
ncbi
and that's info ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
so that's the conclusion of the webinar
for today so thanks everybody for coming
please you know keep in touch with us
via the info option
and we'll get you through this just fine
okay thanks